[Music]
nlp so neuro-linguistic programming
let's dive into that i would love any
and all perspectives again be helpful to
define terms for those who aren't
familiar well nlp where do i start i
mean it's it's a bag of stuff as us
psychologists would refer to it it's
lots of different ideas isn't one thing
i've heard nlp referred to as nothing
like psychology
and there is maybe some truth to that
for some parts of it so i think some
parts of it have shown to be valid
i think
mirroring a mirroring where you mirror
the other person's body language and in
order to get rapport and so on there's
probably something to that
some of the the kind of verbal priming i
think there might be something to that
unfortunately there's big parts of it
that are
you know just don't work out at all
so to get back to lying there's this
notion that if you look in a certain
direction you'll be lying and if you
look in another direction you're telling
the truth
and i can never remember which way round
is it's like up to the left is lying and
down to the right telling the truth or
something
and it's a very widely believed idea
and so a few years ago we put it to the
test so we we had a bunch of students
we asked them to go into an office and
either steal a mobile phone that was in
the office
or to to just put it into the drawer and
then they they came out and they all
tried to convince us that put it into
the draw so some of them were lying some
of them were telling the truth we could
look at their eye movements nlp didn't
work out at all didn't matter where they
were looking
and you might argue that's not a very
what psychologist would call
ecologically valid task i it's an
artificial task
so we then went to look at these very
public kind of press conferences that
the police hold sometimes in the uk when
there's been a missing person's case
where relatives come on and appeal for
the missing person
in some instances
it turns out that the person doing the
appeal is the person who's guilty of the
crime
so we know those people are lying during
that press conference
equally we know in many of the press
conferences the people were telling the
truth it was a genuine appeal so again
we could look at the eye movements again
we did it
no indication at all no hint that this
idea that certain eye movements
associated
with with lying or telling the truth so
it's very important with all of these
ideas
about psychology is to put them to the
test because otherwise you might be you
know
using some kind of tip or technique
that's got no validity at all and we're
lying you know it really matters
so nlp then net net
i don't know what the sort of purported
applications are of of nlp but would you
say kind of safe discard
in terms of paying attention to it is a
developable skill
no i i would say
think about what you're trying to do
think about what the practitioners are
telling you and then look at the
academic literature to see if it holds
water
if it's a really important thing like
whether someone's telling the truth or
lying if you're just having fun
what does it matter
but but yes it's important that i would
always fall back on the academic work
because it's not just nlp there are so
many things out there which you know
everybody does based on psychology and
actually the academic work doesn't
underpin it so you know brainstorming
for example terrible idea you know let's
all get together and kick around an idea
and come up with new ideas it doesn't
work it's not particularly effective
what's far more effective is that
everyone thinks of three ideas three
solutions the problem before they go
into the room and you go around the
group and everyone mentions their three
ideas
because that way you don't get an
individual dominating the group and
certain ideas not getting a hearing
so again it's just really important i
think to go hold on a second if this
matters if this is important what's the
evidence which was underpinned by the 59
seconds book
you